Whether as the first day of school, an important interview or the day of your wedding - pimples
You'll find a way to appear at the most inconvenient times. But why show and how we can
Get rid of her?
The term "pore" is just another term for "hair follicles" and your body
And covered by. There is a gland inside the follicle produces an oil called
Sebum, which secrete on the skin to maintain the moisture of hair and body. But if they become
Hair follicles are resistant to dead skin cells and oils, causing clogging. Sebum
The production will continue but is trapped inside the pores, making it swell.
This is where the bacteria come to play, feeding on dead skin and sebum which can
Unfortunately lead to infection. Your immune system responds by sending blood to the area
Which gives the appearance of redness and inflammation, and a lot of white blood cells come to the area also,
To remove the infection. When white blood cells die, they meet with
Dead skin and sebum, showing a pimple filled with pus.
If a subcutaneous occlusion occurs, a white pimple, known as "whiteheads", will be made
If a clot occurs above the skin and discoloration of the black is known as "blackheads".
This is the result of melanin in dead skin cells interacting with oxygen creating a black color
It is not dirty.
We get most pimples when we are teenagers because of the increased amount of androgen hormones
Such as testosterone in our bodies at the onset of puberty. Testosterone increases production
Sebum doubles, which increases the rate of blockages. But grains can appear at any time
- often - result from stressful events. "Cortisol" stress hormone, increases the amount
Inflammation in your body (which means more red spikes on your face), can also suppress your immune system
This means that your body can not fight bacteria that cause acne.
So how can we fight warts? For normal injuries clean your face to remove
Excess oil and thus prevent clogging of pores and peeling from time to time to remove the dead skin
Will help, although acne often can not be resolved this way. It is important to remember
Hygiene and diet do not play a major role in acne, but in genetics
Hormones. Many of the available drugs such as benzoyl peroxide kill a specific type of acne-causing bacteria
Salicylic acid, which helps remove dead skin clots, retinoids, which reduce the production of sebum
And a variety of other; although some drugs can have serious side effects. At
Women, some success has been observed when using oral contraceptives, which reduce the production of ovaries
Of the androgen hormones, thus reducing sebum. Of course, consult with
A doctor about which system is best suited to you is always better
But new treatments loom with the help of science! Study
Individuals who do not have acne scientists have noticed that bacteria usually have
Acne is also found on their skin, but of a different breed. It turned out that
The same bacteria with little variation in genes cause healthier skin. With this in mind,
Future treatments may include a deeper look at the level of bacteria, and whether it is
Changing the germs of your skin can treat pimples.
We are really happy to work with Bill and Melinda Gates in support
Their annual message for the year as "two great powers we wish"! every year
They launch a message to receive consideration of global issues, and the question this year is: how will it be
Your precious superpower? You will have more clean energy such as Bill or for more time
Like Melinda, this means one thing in rich countries and another thing for the world
the poorest. It's a chance for positive change in the world - so I find something
You are passionate about him and know more about him. Check the message on the link in Saduk
Description, we will post the ideas of the supercomputers on Instagram with #superpowerforgood.